[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau débrief du dock consacrée
aujourd'hui un quartier emblématique du
caire la capitale égyptienne
un quartier situé au sud est de la ville
et qui est de fait sa déchetterie à ciel
ouvert entre 50 et 80 mille personnes y
vivent et travaillent 90% d'entre elles
sont de religion chrétienne copte
minoritaire en egypte on les appelle les
à baline littéralement ceux qui gère les
ordures
leur travail consiste à récupérer les
ordures de toute la ville du caire les
trier les revendre c'est tout un monde
qui s'organise autour du traitement des
déchets les conditions de vie sont
difficiles le travail pénible et peu
rémunérés mais malgré tout cela on y
découvre une vie bouillonnante et une
population qui ne se laisse pas abattre
et ce ramassage des déchets fait tourner
l'économie du quartier et permet dans
certains cas une véritable ascension
sociale à ses habitants pour en parler
nous sommes avec bénédicte flora bonjour
bonjour alors bénédicte flora vous êtes
maître de conférences en géographie à
l'université de tours et chercheuse à
lehman équipe monde arabe et
méditerranée vous avez résider quatre
ans au caire où vous continuez de
retourner régulièrement
c'est depuis 2007 que vous vous
intéressez au récupérateur de déchets au
système de gestion des déchets à ce
service public en egypte mais aussi au
maroc et en turquie depuis 2007 vous
avez aussi commencé un travail de
terrain sur les ferrailleurs de la
région parisienne vous avez notamment
publié un article qui s'intitule faire
la ferraille en banlieue parisienne
glané bricoler et transgresser avec
pascal garret dans la revue échos géo
bénédicte flora qu'avez vous pensé du
reportage ce qu'il montre bien la
réalité
pour vous qui avez vécu plusieurs années
au caire
tout d'abord je voulais vous remercier
pour cette invitation et j'ai en effet
trouvez que le documentaire était très
intéressante et justes et mettez en
lumière de nombreux paradoxes de cette
communauté des à baline dont vous avez
donc voilà vous savez introduit donc
vous venez de parler et pour reprendre
vos propos
il faut effectivement savoir ce que
montre là aussi le documentaire qu'il
s'agit d'une communauté invisibilité
très stigmatisés parce que travaillant
avec les déchets elle vend des cochons
animal impur dans dans le monde arabe et
qui en même temps à des compétences
professionnelles et des savoir-faire
tout à fait tout à fait exceptionnelle
et je trouve que le documentaire met en
lumière met en exergue à la fois ce
paradoxe de la communauté qu'on imagine
uniquement misérable vivent dans les
déchets mais pas que puisque on voit
bien ses savoir faire et ses compétences
donc c'était très agréablement surprise
par le sérieux de mon de cette
investigation les personnes que vous
avez rencontré également que les
documentaristes ans rencontré dans dans
leur travail et pour certaines que je
connais que j'ai eu plaisir à retrouver
dans le film
oui et bien parlons-en alors pour entrer
dans le vif du sujet je vous propose de
commencer directement avec un premier
extrait c'est le tout début du reportage
il annonce la couleur notamment
visuellement
regardez c'est à baline ville poubelle
[Musique]
kirollos saad à 10 ans il a passé son
enfance dans la ville des ramasseurs de
déchets de sa balle in mais il a de la
chance contrairement à d'autres enfants
de son âge
kirilow snap a encore dû commencer à
faire le sale boulot je ne veux pas que
mon fils face aux london le ballet parce
que ma femme travaille donc signé frais
toutes les femmes de ma famille
travaille de manière générale les
enfants commençaient à aider les adultes
quand ils ont entre 10 et 12 ans parfois
même plus tôt si leur famille est
vraiment dans le besoin
on peut donc voir beaucoup d'enfants
plus jeune que lui bien travaillé goergl
a hérité de ce travail de son père qui
était aussi ramasseurs de déchets ils se
sont installés à zaba line il y à 45 ans
les techniques de recyclage ont à peine
changé depuis
[Musique]
la famille de gaza d' collecte tri et
nettoie plusieurs types de déchets à la
fois en règle générale les hommes
s'occupent du métal et du plastique
cette machine les doigts le plastique
et celle ci le broie
la première le nettoie et la seconde le
droit ensuite celle ci le sèche avant
qu'ils ne soient broyés en poudre enfin
nous le mettons dans des sacs et
l'envoyons à l'usiné
[Musique]
alors c'est assez frappant d'emblée un
bénédicte florin ce quartier du sud est
du caire cette ville dans la ville noyée
littéralement sous les déchets en tout
genre
c'est véritablement une ville poubelle
comme lundi que le nom du reportage ce
petit de garde ce petit garçon de 10 ans
qui roule aux qui jouent au foot avec
ses copains parmi les détritus les sacs
les bouteilles en plastique et puis son
père dont on apprend qu'il a hérité de
son travail de son père à lui il ya 45
ans du coup première question comment se
fait-il que ce soit les coptes minorité
chrétienne d'egypte qui s'occupe depuis
des décennies des déchets d'une des
villes les plus denses du monde pourquoi
ce travail est réservé à cette
communauté avec des techniques de
recyclage qui n'ont pas changé depuis
les années 30 si je comprends bien
et si on se réfère à vos travaux à ce
sujet alors je vous remercie pour cette
question parce que elle permet de à
grands traits reconstituer une histoire
de cette communauté
il s'agit de migrants ruraux qui
viennent de moyenne et de haute egypte
poussés par la pauvreté dans les années
1930 et qui arrive donc au caire et
comme ils sont comme vous l'avez dit
chrétien copte
ils ont le droit et dont la possibilité
d'élever des cochons dont la viande est
vendue à l'est aux communautés
étrangères qui réside à ce moment là au
caire ville très cosmopolite
lorsqu'il arrive au caire ils vont
commencer par collecter les déchets
organiques donc les déchets organiques
ce sont les résidus alimentaires les
épluchures de légumes etc pour nourrir
leurs animaux
mais assez rapidement ils vont se
retrouver sous la tutelle d'une
corporation de récupérateurs musulmans
qui sont des gens venant des oasis qu'on
appelle les warriors et qui eux depuis
très longtemps je dirais presque des
scripts et des siècles récupérer des
combustibles pour
au four des hammams des bains des bains
maures des bains douches et au four des
restaurants et donc six migrants du sud
de l'egypte les à baline futur d'aller
une copte vont parce qu'ils doivent
gagner leur vie
travailler pour c c'est cette
corporation musulmane à ddo résiste mais
progressivement le système va se mettre
en place et les les à baline prendre et
bien de l'ampleur également
démographiquement et prendre la main sur
cette récupération des déchets avec un
point qui me semble tout à fait
intéressant à savoir un partage des
quartiers de classe moyenne et des
quartiers aisés du caire là où les
déchets sont intéressants parce qu'il
faut préciser qu'ils ne vont pas ou très
rarement récupérer dans les quartiers
pauvres populaires qu'ils produisent peu
de déchets donc ils vont se répartir en
territoire de collecte rue paru sous
quartiers par sous-quartier contre
chaque famille des zones dans lesquelles
ils vont aller collecter et là aussi
c'est très original avec un système de
collecte en porte à porte qui signifie
que c'est
c'est à baline les hommes et les garçons
vont tous les matins au petit matin
convient pas trop de circulation dans
leur propre chacun dans son propre
territoire de collecte et ils vont aller
chercher l'entière poubelles de chaque
famille de cairotes de ces classes
moyennes de ces quartiers de classes
moyennes pardon et de et de catégories
aisées poubelles qui vont ramener dans
l'un des sept quartiers parce qu'en fait
il ya sept quartiers de 2 à malines dont
celui montré dans le documentaire acquis
et bien sûr le plus grand et qui dispose
des techniques de recyclage assez évolué
de très nombreux ateliers et c'est pas
comme vous l'avez dit que les enfants et
surtout les filles et les jeunes femmes
les femmes vont
riez avons effectué le premier tri de
ces poubelles
je voulais juste peut-être apporter une
petite précision sur le travail des
enfants qui je pense peut choquer
interrogé en tous les cas le
téléspectateur
s'il est vrai que jusqu'aux années 90
les enfants étaient très peu souvent
scolarisés et voilà essentiellement
affectés à ce tri à ce travail sur des
déchets on a vu vraiment à partir des
années 80 90 1 un gros efforts faits en
terme de scolarisation et pour de
nombreuses familles dès que c'est
possible
l'une des priorités ça sera de
scolariser les enfants et même si c'est
possible de les envoyer à l'université
faire des études supérieures et ça
rejoint ce que vous disais au début à
savoir qu'il ya une ascension possible
une ascension sociale une ascension
professionnelle possible bien sûr pas
pour tout le monde mais quand elle est
envisageable
c'est vraiment une priorité pour de
nombreuses familles et peut être que ça
nuance un peu la dimension parfois
misérabiliste qu'on a de ces quartiers
et de et des abeilles
alors effectivement vous avez parlé des
techniques de recyclage ces machines
qu'on voit dans le reportage ces
machines qui nettoie qui broie le
plastique le métal
alors d'où vient-il on voit qu'elles
sont assez rudimentaire mais visiblement
ce n'est pas le cas comme vous le dites
est ce le gouvernement égyptien qui les
a mis à disposition en quelque sorte d
habitants d à baline est ce que ce sont
des ong qui ont participé à ces
installations afin de faciliter le
travail des ramasseurs de déchets il y à
des multinationales qui sont mêlés
expliquez nous alors c'est une question
en jeu très très pertinente
jusqu'aux années 80 le recyclage est
plutôt artisanale ce qui va bouleverser
la vie du quartier de manchiyat nasser
dont voilà le
montré dans le documentaire c'est
l'arrivée de l'électricité à partir du
moment où l'électricité est installé le
recyclage a va basculer de sa dimension
technique très artisanal a une dimension
quasi industrielle en fait il faut bien
imaginer qu'on n'est pas du tout dans
une décharge d'ailleurs le paysage
urbain architectural le montre on n'est
pas dans la décharge la décharge qu on a
des images dans les pays du sud où là on
est vraiment dans le reste du reste très
très souliers là c'est pas le cas et
l'arrivée donc de l'électricité va
permettre la multiplication progressif
bien sûr ça se fait pas d'un coup d'un
seul de ces petits ateliers l'achat de
machines outils comme des broyeuses et
puis progressivement et c'est ça ta
grande intelligence d à baline la
confection par eux mêmes la fabrication
par eux mêmes de ces machines outils et
je vous donne un exemple qui me semble
très intéressant c'est le cas à partir
des années 2000 plus tôt même 2010 de
ces fameuses extrudeuse pour recycler le
plastique sont des machines qui prennent
beaucoup places qui sont très complexes
à fabriquer qui valent entre 40000 les
100000 euros donc très coûteuse et que
font les à bali les achète une
extrudeuse il a démonté en pièces
détachées pour voir comment elles
fonctionnent et ils vont avec leurs
propres outils notamment des matériaux
récupérés refaire des extrudeuse qui va
bien sûr seront beaucoup moins coûteuses
que celles achetées à l'étranger
donc on a vu vraiment un essor de ses
capacités compétent ce recyclage à
partir des années 2000 avec un taux de
recyclage qui est absolument
exceptionnel dans le monde qui est de 80
%
en fait ce que les chiffonniers du caire
naïve par le site les personnes dans le
monde
j'exagère à peine on arrive alors aux
cycles et donc il ya un savoir-faire une
inventivité tout à fait tout à fait
exceptionnel dans ses compétences au
recyclage et peut-être juste pour finir
sur cette question ce qui est aussi
intéressant dans les paradoxes
c'est que c'est cette expérience
professionnelle au cycle âge elle et
elle est connue à l'étranger elle est
connue par les bailleurs de fonds elle
est souvent montré en exemple je sais
pas je pense au sommet de la terre dans
des colloques sur l'environnement à
l'extérieur de l'egypte mais elle est
absolument pas reconnu en egypte eux
mêmes et lorsqu'on en parle des
chiffonniers d un bel hymne en egypte
c'est toujours quand il ya des crises
des crises des conflits avec avec eux
avec la communauté comme vous l'avez
évoqué en parlant de ces multinationales
qui qui vont arriver au caire au début
des années 2000 mais je vous rends la
parole parce que c'est un peu notre une
autre histoire
effectivement c'est très complexe et
très organisés en tout cas merci pour
vous éclairage on se retrouve juste
après une courte plus pas tout de suite
[Musique]
de retour dans ce nouveau numéro du
débrief du dock intitulé à buy-in ville
poubelle
nous sommes avec bénédicte florent
maître de conférences en géographie à
l'université de tours et chercheuse à
lehman équipe monde arabe et
méditerranéen qui connaît très bien le
sujet ça je peux vous le dire c'est sûr
je vous propose de regarder un autre
extrait de ce reportage à beinwil
poubelle on est plongé cette fois au
beau milieu du plus grand marché du
caire qui se tient le vendredi
situé en bordure du quartier des ordures
on y trouve de tout notamment ce qui
provient des poubelles regarder
vous voyez il ya aussi des choses comme
ça dans les ordures c'est du maquillage
aimargues ça ça doit être un truc pour
les massages vous savez de quel genre de
massage il s'agit non je sais pas du
tout elle le sait elle m'a dit de lire
attentivement ce qui avait marqué dessus
vous le savez vous c'est pour les femmes
pour les hommes
ces choses deviennent des poubelles saut
d'essai alors ils vendent ces petites
choses
la bible les gens vont au marché et il
crie comme ça venez par ici venez par et
s'ils ne voulaient pas où vous irez en
enfer
venez acheter vieil homme qui achète
[Musique]
ça coûte 10 livres dits libres mais
s'est cassé
donne moi notre pays
4 lille 4 lille entre moi l'argent c'est
le plus gros marché du vendredi du caire
il est situé près de la cité des
ramasseurs de déchets les gens viennent
acheter des cadeaux pour leurs proches
et tout ce qui peut être nécessaire à la
maison alors bénédicte florin on voit
dans le reportage que les objets qui ont
été jetés aux ordures sans être
consommés sont récupérés et revendus et
je pense notamment à ce passage assez
rigolo finalement ou esat naïm un des
habitants et ramasseurs de déchets
montre un flacon d'huile de massage
intime d'une marque très célèbre et il
ne prend la rigolade et fait mine de pas
savoir vraiment ce que c'est puis
finalement il explique que ce genre de
produit se revend sur le marché on nous
explique que le petit kirollos trouve
tout ce dont il a besoin pour jouer vous
qui connaissait très bien le caire on
imagine que vous vous êtes déjà rendu
sur ce marché comment ça se passe là bas
oui ce sont les marchés aux puces
est ce ce que l'on voit bien ici c'est
l'économie de la pauvreté tout est
récupérable et tout est aussi à acheter
pour des égyptiens qui sont dans un
contexte économique extrêmement
difficile
donc rien ne rien ne se perd alors
peut-être que alors que oui peut-être un
petit mot sur ses béquilles et qui
effectivement arpentent les rues du
caire en criant beke mais qui est et on
sait qu'on va pouvoir leur vendre
quelques petits objets sur ses marchés
aux puces roues aussi on retrouve les
les
les abary l'un ses béquilles et au fait
c'est un héritage déroba bkv cas qui
étaient des italiens est là aussi ça
envoie au caire ville cosmopolite un des
années 1920 30 etc qui étaient des
sortes de brocanteurs ambulants et donc
c'est un héritage de cette histoire
international de mont de la ville
peut-être que pour
ans et là aussi on peut je dirais quand
même que par rapport à ce que on ce que
fabrique à par rapport à l'économie
quasi industrielle de quartier de
manchiyet nasr de ce quartier des abymes
cette dimension là les secondaires c'est
une économie de la pauvreté qui est bien
là qui est essentiel pour pour beaucoup
de personnes mais qui ne doit pas non
plus masquer la montée en puissance
d'entrepreneurs des déchets qui sont de
véritables voilà entreprises qui vont
exporter à l'étranger qui sont intégrés
au ca qui sont considérés comme du
secteur informel bien sûr c'est dans
l'informel est très en lien avec le
secteur formel et les usines qui vont
utiliser ces matériaux de seconde main
pour fabriquer des objets des objets
recyclés
donc c'est ça aussi l'intérêt du de cet
espace que montre le votre votre
reportage
c'est ce paradoxe entre cette économie
de la pauvreté ce tri des déchets à même
à mains nues à même les déchets de la
part des femmes et des enfants
d'une part et d'autre part mais tout ça
est en synergie en constitue un système
et d'autre part donc ces entrepreneurs
des mines des déchets cette exportation
vers la chine d'autres pays
ces machines très moderne 7
ce quartier aussi qui est lui qui est
loin d'être un didon ville puisque le
documentaire montre des immeubles de
cinq six étages relativement consolidé 1
avec là aussi quelque chose intéressante
qui est la séparation entre le le sale
les déchets sont au rez de chaussée sont
triés dans les rues donc ça c'est le sol
c'est le niveau du sale et et on a des
appartements dans les étages où là on a
une propreté tout à fait spectaculaire
parce que justement il faut s'élancer et
moi je vais beaucoup parce que justement
on va revenir sur ces questions là il ne
reste plus beaucoup de temps
et j'aimerais vous faire partager un
dernier extrait qui m'a vraiment frappé
celui on voit que le business des
déchets et pour certains très fructueux
je vous invite ensuite à donner votre
avis
art.d cheratte el mouradi est l'une des
personnes les plus riches de sa balle in
il aime se considérer comme le maire de
la ville des ramasseurs de déchets mais
officiellement un tel poste n'existe pas
selon certaines rumeurs cheratte à
contrôler personnellement la vente de
toute la vérité aux recycleurs ceux qui
sont heureux lui permet d'engranger des
profits fabuleux
il ya une villa avec un luxueux
pigeonnier tout près de l'entrée de la
déchetterie shehata ne touche jamais aux
ordures lui même qui ne fait que gérer
le processus il ne s'occupe même pas de
la propreté de sa propre maison
il a une femme de ménage pour ça
[Musique]
qu'attendez-vous du gouvernement nous
avons besoin de véhicules modernes pour
transporter les déchets de la ville vers
la déchetterie
c'est un équipement moderne et sûre ici
le gouvernement approuve le projet de
traitement des déchets
ce sera tout à fait positif pour les
ramasseurs là nos corps sont couverts de
bactéries nous sommes nés de père qui
est aussi ramasser des ordures asa ben
ali
les microbes et bactéries des
déchetteries sont déjà en nous mais ils
ne font que renforcer notre système
immunitaire contre les maladies si
j'étais un citoyen ordinaire je ne
ressemblerait pas ça aujourd'hui
bénédicte florin alors moi honnêtement
ça m'a frappé cet homme chez raphaël mon
gars disent qu'on voit dans le reportage
on le voit tel un seigneur dans sa villa
avec son pigeonnier ils fument sont
arguent-ils et tranquille il a du
personnel
est-ce que derrière tout cela il ya un
côté mafieux comme à naples en italie
par exemple où il est bien connu que la
mafia contrôle le traitement des déchets
ou pas du tout et ce qu'on assiste ici
au contraire à un exemple d'économie
avec la possibilité d'une véritable
ascension sociale
c'est ce que vous aviez l'air de dire
alors là aussi c'est une question
intéressante
je pense que les mes collègues qui ont
travaillé sur sur le karting moi même
n'avons jamais jamais vu deux dimensions
mafieuses donc voilà on est dans un
système tout à fait tout à fait
différent un système communautaire à la
fois très très hiérarchisée avec des
dominations et il ya des dominations
professionnels là vous avez vous en avez
montré un exemple mais en même temps une
communauté qui qui fonctionne de façon
très anglo gamiq qui peut-être
solidaires et soudés en tout cas part
par la dimension religieuse également le
façon de faire du gouvernement contraire
contre cette communauté ce qui soude la
communauté est encore une fois qui
n'empêche pas des relations de
domination et de domination comme voilà
ces leaders ces grands grossistes qui
ont été eux mêmes souvent petit
récupérateur gamins qui ont commencé par
un père la récup dans les rues une
domination aussi des rapports de mouy
nomination hommes femmes adultes enfants
bien sûr ça je ne le nie pas du tout
mais on mais je ne parlerais pas de
mafia pas du tout pour le alors
bénédicte florent malgré l'insalubrité
de l'environnement on sent que ce
quartier vit quand même il ya des
magasins des marchés des boucheries des
cafés où les habitants viennent se
reposer fumer la chicha et ses légendes
globalement ont le sourire c'est
incroyable à dire comme ça mais les gens
ne semblent pas malheureux même si c'est
un raccourci évidemment mais on sent une
entraide entre les habitants une sorte
de fatalité ironique qu'on entend chez
les habitants interviewés dans le
reportage et puis il ya cette ascension
sociale qui reste possible dans ce
fonctionnement dans l'impression qu'on
est quand même loin des décharges
fumantes à ciel ouvert de certains pays
d'afrique
oui ce que vous dites est tout à fait
juste et moi je les compte à ce qu'ont
constaté dans mon travail notamment avec
masques à garer à casablanca
chez les récupérateurs ii de casablanca
ou à istanbul
lamont le regard misérabiliste et
stigmatisant que l'on peut avoir sur ces
récupérateurs n'est pas du tout ressenti
de la même façon par eux mêmes
même s'ils ne sont pas dupes de leurs
conditions de vie de leurs conditions de
travail du fait de pas de ne pas être
reconnu et c'est là il ya peut-être
quelque chose de particulier c'est des
égyptiens c'est leur sens de l'humour et
de la dérision qui laisse aux 20 par
rapport annuel à 7
c'est cette perception misérabiliste que
l'on pourrait avoir
ils sont résistants alors c'est amusant
l'extrait puisque shehata dit on ne peut
pas tomber malade on est vacciné contre
tous en même temps on a des maladies de
peau donc c'est de cette façon là bon
ton on résiste on est vaccinés par les
sens parce qu'on travaille dans l'est
dans les déchets ils se sont aussi des
intérêts quelque part à dire ça parce
qu'il sait très bien que derrière il ya
son affaire et à son business évidemment
il ne va pas dire ah bah oui il ya
beaucoup de maladies tandis que naim dit
au contraire que bah il faut pas se
voiler la face non plus des seringue
pleine de sens qui s'enfonce dans la
peau ça existe aussi
c'est très dangereux il ya un véritable
problème de 200 sanitaires oui tout à
fait à l inverse faut pas tomber dans
l'angélisme et donc les les blessures
les maladies respiratoires la charge
d'eads et des sacs qui peuvent peser
jusqu'à 100 kg sur leur dos et c'est
bien sûr tout ça c'est à prendre en
compte est d'ailleurs assez voilà on
peut quand même saluer le travail des
ong qui qui à maxime et qui vont
vacciner beaucoup d'enfants non etc et
mais encore face est un paradoxe avec
une sorte de résistance ou de façon de
contrer le fait de travailler avec dents
sur le déchet qui est on est aussi fort
on peut résister on veut une
reconnaissance et ça c'est un point
important il me semble c'est 7
cette prise de parole des leaders des
leaders du quartier et zap naim
notamment où un chien matin qui est
responsable des syndicats qui demandent
un droit où travaillent une
reconnaissance au travail pas forcément
d'être formalisé les d'être au moins
reconnus dans leur travail et c'est ça
aussi les relations parfois très
conflictuelles avec le gouvernement
égyptien ou dans d'autres cas avec les
autorités locales dans d'autres pays et
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de choses à dire
à propos de ce reportage passionnant
saab à hinwil poubelle merci à vous
bénédicte florin d'avoir accepté notre
invitation j'en profite pour rappeler
que vous avez initié avec claudia
cirelli un réseau de chercheurs tous
spécialistes de questions autour des
déchets qui ont construit une exposition
à partir de leurs travaux sur cette
thématique
cette exposition est destinée à un grand
public elle a été présentée dans de
nombreux endroits en france et à
l'étranger pour en savoir plus rendez
vous sur sud point hypothèse point org
et merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
vous pouvez évidemment retrouver cette
interview en podcast est en replay sur
notre site internet
rt france point tv excellente journée à
tous
[Musique]